we will get to those stories in just a
moment but first we do have breaking
news here at six o'clock you are looking
at what's left of a pretty large fire
near the 215 in South Buffalo that broke
out about 4 30 this afternoon the smoke
was so intense on the fireball so huge
the 215 was down to one lane in that
part of the freeway and we're going to
show you some video from earlier when
that fire was just raging incredible
flames and smoke look at those Flames
just jumping from that building we do
have a crew at that fire we we will have
a live report coming up in just a little
bit we can tell you this was a two alarm
fire when it first broke out and we are
keeping an eye on it County fire will be
updating as we're told here probably in
the next 15 minutes or so